[Music]
a woman
as ryan would say a woman love him
claims her boyfriend gets up to 100
erections a day
who's counting wow is there like a
[ __ ] fitbit around his dick they got
a guy
that's one
he's the guy at the club doing the
clickers and is it prolonged
he just twitched it it has to be zero
degrees can be prolonged if that's a
hundred do you have to go from soft to
hard everything and
that's what's happening that must be so
annoying for you guys though
for you guys
yeah for you guys
i'll [ __ ] have a dick don't you guys
don't you guys titties get hard though
yeah
that's true i heard some women say that
i heard this i heard somebody say that
one time like i'm talking about like an
erection though though like because i
feel like it's just right before you
about to like come or like you're horny
and [ __ ] and you're just like getting
blue balls all entirely well some of it
some of it is the classic nrb is just
blood flow you know what i mean it's
just healthy [ __ ] after a nap
like sometimes when it's just like uh
like uh i remember the whole no reason
boner type [ __ ] right like you'd be like
sitting down for a while in class by the
way but and like if you like got up
suddenly there's like blood flow right
isn't that uncomfortable but when's the
last time you got an nrv though
it's like yeah it's like non-sexual
though yeah it's not sexual it can't
turn sexual can i still get those random
boners
oh it's turning sexual not as frequent
as like
high school not like high school high
school was like every [ __ ] minute
dude like i couldn't even study i just
go home can't wait to jack off yeah
there's a definite hormonal difference
and then you take a nap and then you get
up you're like all right now i'm gonna
study and then you're like no i gotta
jack off and you [ __ ] wipe off the
[ __ ] books off your tape you gotta
make a scene out of it
right cause you're too young to [ __ ]
put a girl on the table so you [ __ ]
wipe it off and you pull up your laptop
on the table and then you do it like
that because you're old enough for that
for kisses
joe has to clear the whole table and
then he can come on it
which i've had done before that's all we
could finish yeah you can't i can't
finish on the books i think i still
stand by my statement isn't that
annoying like isn't that just
what's the female equivalent of getting
a boner
it's only annoying if you're at the
doctor's and he's about to come in and
you get a random boner and you can't
that sucks you don't want to be soft it
sucks too because wait because you guys
[ __ ] yourself before you see the doctor
always especially if it's a dude one
time yeah the one time i did it
i felt embarrassed i was like yeah the
doctor started laughing at me he's like
where was this little baby's penis she's
like oh my god the stethoscope on your
dick was like is everything okay nick
yeah he's like i'm gonna get my
magnifying glass for this well i know
what nick's here for no we don't have
dick lengthening surgery
and i was like oh geez doc you don't
that's the only time i remember it being
annoying because you're wearing that
gown thing and if you have a boner the
whole thing goes boom
yeah or like when you uh when you get
like a massage or something like that
and you're in like [ __ ] asia or
something like that old asian guy they
make you [ __ ] put on those like uh
netted little things for massages you
ever been to asia get those massages no
i've heard about them though they give
you like a little net thing and just
fully show [ __ ] yeah and then somebody
comes in you're like mesh underwear yeah
like a mesh [ __ ] little underwear
like like a [ __ ] fishnets talking
i [ __ ] you know
this who puts on a fishnet stocking
underwear and the guy told him everybody
does this it's okay
and the guy's like kinky he's very kinky
this guy's into it i can't believe we
put him on you know what you never got a
massage in singapore nah
i have but i didn't have to wear
fishnets oh [ __ ] you know what i don't
have to wear a mulan
if you go
they scrub you right so so for you if
you go to the spot you're butt naked
yeah you're butt naked and my friend was
like hey
did your guy straddle you and we're like
straddle you and he goes yeah you go so
he said he was lying down like this
and then this one [ __ ] went over him
like that like a log right yeah and then
that fool [ __ ] went over and he just
started scrubbing his chest like this
hell yeah
and he's like i felt like that was so
unnecessary
that sounds really the guy was naked too
depending on who you asked you know
wow that's crazy but um yeah so a woman
is claiming her boyfriend gets up to a
hundred erections a day saying it
happens every single place they go this
chick's name is vicki brown she's 31 and
her boyfriend's name is lucas martin
she's 17 39. that's a disorder at that
point right right damn she must be hot
as [ __ ] yeah that's probably it uh i can
i can send some photos she got a
heart-shaped ass
nothing this man can do he's always just
going oh baby
that's where we're at with them damn i'd
be hard all the time too hey yo
no joe the one the chicks on the right
oh
i don't know
so uh
she literally says everywhere they go
even with like other people around
whether it's sitting down for dinner
going out for coffee going to the movies
getting into a taxi whatever the [ __ ] he
can get an erection and it just happens
like that anywhere from 50 to 100 times
a day even to the point where even if
other people are around sometimes he
literally is just like oh you can only
laugh it off so he can't so when he
wears basketball shorts or sweats and
he's like at 24 hour fitness playing
pickup games you can't flip it up
you got to flip it up you gotta flip it
up the thing is it only happens when
she's around
get the [ __ ] out of here so it's like a
wi-fi [ __ ] transmitter was this a
propaganda bit
he's like we get it you love your
[ __ ] life
[Music]
it's not pandering
like just hate child support
[Laughter]
uh she says he has a constant need for
sex you know what this is this is oh so
it's actual horny bonus this is a brag
from the wife i i was thinking it might
have been a disorder so i was like he
always wants to [ __ ] only me yeah yeah
yeah
that's awful
sounds like dude yeah
good for her she's getting that dick so
you know what she sounds crazy like a
brag that went way too far i know yeah
she looks like my [ __ ] was [ __ ]
collapsed
yeah she says through the whole
relationship he always had an erection
in shops restaurants and the gym there's
no rest from it all and i just wondered
if any other couples are the same that's
the there you go you know it's just
strange that's the giveaway that's the
giveaway i just want to know if it's
like does anybody else have a big house
and like you have to have like four air
conditioners that's the line that's
literally gonna get cold it's like are
you kidding me the line right now so i'm
like okay which one controls which air
conditioner
when everyone goes i know why would you
ask that i know great dude you guys know
when you're like [ __ ] your husband
like a hundred times a day oh it's so
much like you know that's nice
like magneto's saying that yeah don't
you guys hate when metal just sticks to
you
now you need to talk like that you
[ __ ] know you have a power a little
british virgin a little british name
you're like jake sucks he's like dude
like guys
i gotta tell you guys like some serious
[ __ ] that happened to me like i almost
died it was [ __ ] crazy i was
suffocating my wife's titties
i'm like you know so [ __ ] big and
perfect you guys know how it is um but
yeah i was just stuck in there i
couldn't get out
and i was like really fearful of my life
i saw my life last night i swear to god
i thought about my kids the whole time
so so is she saying anything about like
her just being tired or her libido can't
match
no she's just talking about this dick
going up everywhere and that's it yeah
that number of a hundred times the same
he can go to sleep with an erection and
wake up with one even though he does not
night shifts there's no change in it at
all it's every single place we are we
have we can be having a perfectly normal
everyday conversation like shall we go
and climb this mountain next weekend and
then he has an erection and also can't
stop cooking for me he'll just start
taking out items and then he starts
cooking for me it's so [ __ ] annoying
we can't even go to a restaurant because
he'll just start cooking for me instead
he keeps paying me alimony we're not
even divorced
like well obviously right next to me
sending me affirmations to my phone like
i'm right next to you affirmations
so does he have anything to say about
that or is this just her her commentary
that he's probably not a real person
it's huge no oh no no i bet he doesn't
exist this guy
cause isn't it like that's what i think
if that was true
most women would be like this is too
much like it would kind of be a lot for
them but she's like does anyone else
have this aj
like shut up dude most women with sex
addiction on [ __ ] uh soft white
underbelly wouldn't be able to keep up
with that [ __ ] yeah that's true
that's crazy yeah there's really
in-depth interviews these women are
still like i cap it at like 20 a day
this is [ __ ] because he was like she
says that he could fall asleep with a
boner that's [ __ ] that's true
you can wake up with one you go you for
obviously you wake up
but fall asleep with a boner you know
how hard that is yeah that's like that
is pretty hard and then fall asleep
that'd be a lot of you'd have to focus
really hard you got to [ __ ] kind of
speak when you're hungry dude yeah you
know what i mean
i'd squeeze one out yeah you just
squeeze it out i i squeeze one out
christ what do you do to your body when
you're masturbating like the last of the
cold game
rolls it up
from the bottom
oh it masturbates strangely that's what
we found out today yeah
joe masturbates in a weird way
before squeeze one out no rub one out
yes rub one out squeeze one minute
we just need that one you guys ever
twisted one out yeah squeeze one out pop
one out you gotta pop it pull it pull it
out pull it all out squeeze one out
what i stringed
we can imagine this is the new version
on the one thousandth one it's
programmed to go squeeze one out
jerky
jerk it come on do it kid flip it swipe
it
so it is annoying if you have an
erection but you can't do anything about
it yeah if you're horny but i never had
blue balls before though because i just
come too fast sometimes i think if
you're horny yeah like imagine taking a
rush out of it if you're horny and you
can't do something about it that's
annoying already regardless men are more
how do i say it's emotional yeah
we don't we have a boner but that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that we
want to have sex yeah i think we have to
have some kind of a of a connection
going on before we can over ourselves
and the boner's got to be able to look
at you know the person in the eye right
you're going to see an episode of
guiding light first
technically so like so let's say you
have a boner but you're not horny so
then you can just sleep right now like
you wouldn't be that annoying right
no we'd probably have to squeeze one out
i think that's where i'm getting
confused because like you're just
telling me that like
it's it's it's not that big of a deal
it's not but then you just have to
squeeze one men are complicated and
that's not a big deal for us half the
guys have bones right now
i haven't had a butter in three years if
i
really focus hard
i get chubs a lot instead of
full-fledged boners like half mash
wouldn't you chubs nobody says instead
of full foot instead of full fledgling
on purpose are you doing this name chubs
a lot
sir
[ __ ] chubb and tug dude
does anybody else get really solid
sometimes
out of nowhere just getting real filled
up anybody grow their child
oh wow bro they're jokes you don't get
my
semi hard half mask half mask i've never
called
i feel like there's a certain
connotation calling it a chub chubbed up
you never you never had a fallen soldier
it's like three fourths of the way a
cherub then you know when you fly the
flag half mass oh half mass that's okay
i call it a national tragedy
somebody must have died then we grew up
in different places
they called it a boston bombing he
called on 911 no
when you you know
cop down one cop down no do uh so do uh
chicks have any uh you know no reason
what gets hard on you guys yeah
like the the it just you know just comes
down a little version can you flex it
can you flex it
can i no no i never just come out yeah
you never have no reason kegels
no reason
no reason key goes there
oh i think
they're just like
you're like seeing a guy and you're just
like oh [ __ ] i just flexed it
yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you take this shirt
off you're like oh my god oh my god it's
totally flexed does putting a tampon
ever get sexual no it never does that's
what a no reason boner is that's a
really well good way to put it is that a
fault of the product or is that
all women
that's true
good question um i think you're just the
tampon is just up to do one job and it's
just to suck the blood in ooh suck
[Laughter]
oh talk more about that oh my gosh
how are you a business owner how has
this worked out for you so well
in the video
and the video
you